[Music]
Adam let honor good boys
yeah I can't be sure it's him I know how
are you okay let me explain cuz I'm as
shocked as anyone else here Adam you
always come in costume as sort of a fun
thing you do that's correct gonna okay
and they told me you were gonna come in
a costume today and so I had them but
they didn't tell me what yeah okay in
the past you've came the first time you
came on the show you came in wearing a
tuxedo yeah okay
second time you came on you were a
buckingham palace guard and last time
you were born
okay now I'll be very honest with you
they did not tell me what you're gonna
be today they said you'll know when he
comes out you're out here and I don't
know what you are well let me let me
explain yeah well so I was born out last
time yeah and I was like well I should
probably be like an even more famous
American comedy character so I was like
I'll be the mask Jim Carrey I was like
Adam that's a genius idea I talked to
myself I thought I Adam you're nailing
that idea and then I talked to my old
friend and mentor Brian stack who used
to work here one of our great all-time
writers yeah all-time everything and he
was like you know Conan really is like a
Civil War buff so you should like do
like robert e lee or or abraham lincoln
I was like stacked your genius I'm gonna
do Abraham Lincoln and then I never
cancelled the guy hired
yeah yeah okay and then so they both
showed up and I hate I don't like
confrontation but I got Conan it it
actually kind of works like I totally
when you came out I immediately
understood thank you
I was pretending to be confused by
chameleon derp stood little ask Abraham
Lincoln somebody signed the Emancipation
[Applause]
looking at myself I feel like I look
like if Shrek disappeared and they found
about a methadone clinic well I look
like a nauseous Joaquin Phoenix
I like it dear you know what you don't
even sound like yourself cuz are those
wooden Ginga I wanted to uh I went to a
makeup lab and had them make me I'm
making for you don't trust you don't
sound anything like your shoes here so
dumb cause be $7,000
[Applause]
incredible waste of your money hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography